I I pick the standard economic
definition of rationality because once
you start incorporating all kinds of
things into rationality it just becomes
a meaningless concept so if you say and
people are rational but yes but I also
care about your welfare and let's add
that as another component of utility
into the equation that every time you
you're making up another part of utility
it means that you're kind of undermining
the concept of rationality and you know
I'm a behavioral economist which means
that most of my work is showing that
people are irrational but I love
economics economics is is beautiful it's
a it's a wonderful theory it's a great
perspective to have and I don't want to
eliminate that I think it has incredible
amount of insights however what behavior
economics teaches us is that economics
is not the whole story it's not
everything and when you come to do
policies or interventions or to give
recommendations for people to how they
want to live their life you want to take
as complete picture as you want as you
can so you want to take the parts of
economics that are accurate and you want
to fill as much as you can
above that from how people actually
behave